elle m'a dit tu dormes épicier la aux
clients vous a merdé pas la vie ça fait
demi heure que j'attends devant votre
cagna d'épicerie là qu'est ce qui se
passe et je faisais la sieste quand
abadie tu dors le 6h15 l'aleba deux mois
ceux-ci s'en remet à quai ce 6 ans vous
voulez suivre en live web en nature
fossé avec et soyez polis la prière de
morrison nature ne parle plus et nature
vous voulez le report on complète marvin
air hockey canada au 2 mai camembert
allez hop ça ira plus vite avec les
asticots sans les asticots world records
il va me faire revenir la transpiration
mais j'ose même pas lui demander le jus
d'orange
il va me demander avec les bulls a les
bus je n'ai plus
c'est pas plus mal var ont gagné du
temps comme ça allez vous mettez une
petite bière et la bière je vous de la
grotte tambour une photo de groupe comme
du paquet de six attaques à 2 12 aux
flashs de corps ou écoutez moi bien je
voudrais du ver rouge de préférence le
vais vous le groupe et dans une
bouteille voyez avec une étiquette
collée avec de la colle alors j je peux
plus là à vous énerver je donne ma
bouteille une étiquette collée avec la
colle royalement la bouteille beauté un
vert bouteille plastique on les petits
commerces alors vous plaignez toute
l'année que vous n'êtes plus de pognon
et plus de clients il faut voir pose est
devenu un maire d'arles et voilà tout ça
parce que hier je les battues à la
pétanque
aujourd'hui il se croyait le nerfs en
boule